okay let's get into audience questions
for the week the first one this is
actually a really interesting question
if
getting out the vote is a valid strategy
for winning elections why isn't
suppressing the vote a valid strategy
we are talking about two different
things here saying to people
you know what none of these candidates
really have your interests in mind
if you vote for anyone you're
reinforcing some status quo or you're
enabling the two-party system or
whatever
even lying to people about the positions
of the candidates
in order to get them to dislike all of
them and stay home
you know that that's electioneering i
prefer people tell the truth but the
point is that
that is a strategy to say let's run a no
vote campaign or a blank vote campaign
or whatever the case may be that's the
opposite of get out the vote
trying to suppress turnout by
uh lying about polling places lying
about voter id rules
pushing voter purges looking to limit
early voting hours or mail-in voting
that is a completely different strategy
one is a strategy of disenfranchising
someone
from voting which is a right the other
is just making the case that it's not in
your interests to vote and
if if people don't understand the
difference between these two things
we're in uh we're we're in real trouble
now
i would disagree with the strategy of
forex i mean listen we saw this
there were lots of people saying i don't
like any there were bernie supporters
who when hillary won or when biden won
said
i don't like trump but i don't like
biden i don't like trump but i don't
like hillary i
i just i'm opting out i don't want to
participate i don't want to
support any of these candidates i
disagreed with them but that's that's
that's not voter suppression that's
saying
i am making the decision to wield my
right to vote
by not voting or voting third party or
whatever the case may be those are
people
with whom we would just talk and figure
out is that a good strategy what is the
goal
what are you trying to attain by doing
that will it actually work to attain
that
there is nothing similar when you
then look at what the republican party
has done to try to suppress the vote
uh trying to have absentee ballots
thrown out
limiting who can get absentee ballots
cutting
sunday voting hours purging people
because they haven't voted in a few
elections by saying these are no longer
really active voters in the sense that
you should be registered
um voter polling intimidation that is
disenfranchisement
convincing people you are making the
country better by not voting
by choosing not to vote i would disagree
with the strategy i think it's always
better to vote
uh in every situation i've seen but
it is a completely different thing and
part of the problem
is that when people don't get it they
might be tricked by that question
they might hear hey you know what it's
true
if getting out the vote is a strategy
why isn't
suppressing the voter strategy well
suppressing
by just saying choose not to vote
protest with us
protest by not voting that's totally
legitimate
uh suppressing in the way that
republicans have been trying to do we
now have over 250 voter suppression
bills
across more than 40 states why because
they didn't suppress enough of the vote
to win in 2020. it's quite that simple a
very different thing
i'm i'm glad to answer the question
there is very little
comparison between the two if you ever
feel
like you just don't have enough time to
read all the books you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular non-fiction books
and distills each one down into an
e-book
or audiobook that you can get through in
just 15 minutes where you're getting all
the key takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from 10 different
books
in an afternoon obviously it's perfect
for exposing yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it i
recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25 percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video